foreign
you have spent time with Jeff what do
you think are some of the most
underappreciated aspects
related to Jeff in any capacity
he's probably the best entrepreneur that
I've ever been around or got to know
like
it's remarkable yeah and it's
multifaceted here's one that I think is
not well discussed so he has a bunch of
traits that make him a great
entrepreneur
the company today is at such a radical
scale
that there's no way and he's not and
he's in the chairman role like he's not
touching all the decisions he's not
touching all the product decisions all
like he has built a organizational
framework to take what Jeff Bezos
believes and run the whole company that
way and that's not well dissected not
well understood
here's a great story I'm riding in an
Uber this is about eight years ago maybe
seven and I always talk to them I always
talk to the drivers because I'm a
shareholder and I always talk to the
driver and I'm asking him you know
something about whether we can stop he
goes well I got to get back down to San
Jose by 2 30. I'm like what happens at 2
30 he goes I have to meet at the Amazon
warehouse at 2 30. I go what's going on
he goes oh they got this new program
they're running where
you show up at 2 30 and they have all
these burner phones and they load your
car with packages and give you a
manifest and then they booked a ride
over Uber and so this was the early days
of same-day delivery yeah that's cool
this is a company that's worth 100
billions of dollars that is running an
experiment on top of uber and yeah I
know for a fact that most of the
companies I've worked with that have
gotten over 20 or 30 million in Revenue
would not run that experiment because
someone would say oh we won't know how
to do the accounting we can't like
that's too much of a hack like whatever
but this large company was super
comfortable running this kind of hack
experiment on this other company yeah
and he showed me the Manifest I looked
at all this stuff of course I called
Uber immediately thereafter and briefed
them that we're being used been this way
but unbelievable right I mean just
unbelievable no other large company
would do that project none zero and so
somehow he's institutionalized this kind
of experimentation and risk seeking and
he's talked about it there's a great
interview with him from code that you
should try and find for the show notes
from four or five years ago and I could
watch it over and over and over it's
like the eagles documentary I could just
watch it again
that'd be okay but it's fascinating they
ask him when does a internal experiment
get killed and he said when the last
person with good judgment gives up
and that's not how other big companies
work they don't run experiments that way
in fact one of the reasons startups can
compete with big companies is because
most big company experiments they run
one test and if it fails they quit and a
startup can't quit because they have to
shut down if they quit so they run
experiment one and two and three and
four and five and then they pivot and do
six and seven and eight and they stay up
all night because it has to work and so
they just get way more shots on gold
than the big companies do
yeah Bezos is also someone is chronicled
a lot of his thinking and
decision-making Frameworks in letters to
shareholders and there there are some
compilations of his letters much like
Warren Buffett yeah they're very good
and and they're very good I mean just
the
to give one example I mean it could be
highly tactical so I mean the reason
that
people who would call internal meetings
would be required to put together I
think it was a six-page document yeah in
the first 30 minutes of the meeting
would be spent reading this meticulous
document and all the reasons for why
that was instituted I mean it's very
concrete it's not
sort of ambiguous
hand wavy stuff so I definitely
recommend people check that out and also
by the way net mirrors back what we
talked about earlier about riding and
and thought process like if you're
forced to write a six page paper it's
much
harder to put that together than it is a
five yeah page PowerPoint
it's easier to leave stuff out like you
really have to think through everything
yeah he's also super curious like beyond
belief
he's willing to change his priors
you know super fast if you got something
wrong
yeah it's something else I mean I think
AWS is maybe top five business move in
the history of the world
um yeah just the notion that they
launched that out of a consumer internet
company and became one of the most
important Enterprise companies it's
fairly unprecedented it's just amazing